en este vídeo quiero abordar un
ejercicio de pregunta abierta de ap
macroeconomía supongamos que la economía
del país x tiene una tasa real de
desempleo del 7 por ciento una tasa
natural de desempleo del 5% y una tasa
de inflación del 3% usar los valores
anteriores para dibujar una gráfica de
las curvas de philips de corto y largo
plazo etiquetadas correctamente indicar
el punto de equilibrio actual de corto
plazo como punto b trazar en la gráfica
los valores numéricos dados arriba pausa
el vídeo si estás inspirado para
resolver esto empezaré a resolverlo
entonces recuerden las curvas de philips
nos muestran la relación teórica entre
la tasa de desempleo y la tasa de
inflación así que voy a poner la tasa de
inflación en el eje vertical como se
hace generalmente y luego en el eje
horizontal pondré la tasa de desempleo
esta va a ser mi tasa de desempleo que
es un porcentaje ahora tenemos que
dibujarlas
de philips de corto y largo plazo
primero vamos a dibujar la curva de
largo plazo porque ya lo hemos visto
antes que en el largo plazo nuestra tasa
de desempleo es la tasa natural de
desempleo y no está relacionada con la
tasa de inflación solo es una línea
vertical así que será una línea vertical
de nuestra tasa natural de desempleo que
es 5% tal vez se vea así entonces le
llamaré curva de phillips de largo plazo
cp lp y va a estar aquí al 5% ahora
tengo que hacer la curva de corto plazo
y esta curva así nos muestra la relación
entre la tasa de inflación y la de
desempleo pensemos en lo que sucede si
tenemos una tasa de desempleo baja
especialmente si está por debajo de la
tasa natural de desempleo entonces hay
mucha demanda de empleo y podrían decir
oye si quieres que trabaje tienes que
pagarme un poco más y eso podría
conducir a una tasa de inflación mayor y
luego si hay muchas personas
desempleadas
estarán dispuestas a trabajar por menos
o probablemente tengan menos dinero en
sus bolsillos como para incrementar la
inflación así que aquí tendremos la
relación inversa entonces aquí tenemos
la curva de phillips de corto plazo cp
cp que está inclinada hacia abajo y nos
dicen que indiquemos el punto de
equilibrio actual de corto plazo como
punto b digamos que este es el punto b
porque nos dicen que en el equilibrio a
corto plazo tenemos una tasa de
desempleo de 7 % y una tasa de inflación
de 3% entonces nuestra tasa de desempleo
es del 7% y nuestra tasa de inflación es
del 3% muy bien vamos a hacer la
siguiente sección supongamos que el
gobierno del país x no toma acciones
para reducir el desempleo en el largo
plazo qué pasará con las siguientes
curvas se moverán a la derecha a la
izquierda o permanecerán iguales aquí
nos dicen curva de oferta agregada a
corto plazo
esta puede ser un poco difícil porque
podrías estar pensando que nos preguntan
acerca de lo que acabamos de dibujar
pero están hablando de oferta agregada
déjenme dibujar una gráfica para
ayudarnos a visualizar esto entonces si
estamos hablando de demanda agregada y
oferta agregada nuestro eje vertical
será el nivel de precios le llamaré
simplemente np y nuestro eje horizontal
va a ser el pib real pib real ahora
vamos a tener una curva de oferta a
largo plazo la cual es vertical esta es
nuestra producción con pleno empleo de
nuestro país entonces esta es la oferta
agregada a largo plazo
lp pero qué pasa con la curva de oferta
agregada a corto plazo bueno esta va a
estar inclinada hacia arriba si los
niveles de precios son bajos
probablemente la gente no deseara
producir mucho y si los niveles de
precios son altos la gente desea
producir más entonces nuestra oferta
agregada a corto plazo se verá así
a cp le voy a poner su 1 porque vamos a
pensar cómo cambia y luego la demanda
agregada se verá así de ah y fíjense que
a nuestro punto de equilibrio justo aquí
le llamaremos su 1 y estamos en un nivel
de precios
np su 1 la dibuje a la izquierda de la
curva de la oferta agregada a largo
plazo la dibuje a la izquierda de la
producción con pleno empleo porque aquí
la economía se encuentra en una recesión
nuestra tasa de desempleo es más alta
que el nivel natural de desempleo
entonces si nuestra tasa de desempleo
real es más alta que la tasa natural de
desempleo qué pasará con la oferta
agregada a corto plazo una manera de
pensar en esto es que dado un nivel de
precios hay gente buscando trabajo es
posible que obtengas más producción o
una cantidad de producción probablemente
a un nivel de precios más bajo porque
hay gente allá afuera compitiendo por
trabajar
entonces tendremos nuestra curva de
oferta agregada a corto plazo movida
hacia la derecha oferta agregada a corto
plazo o acp sub-21 nuestro nivel de
precios de equilibrio será menor nivel
de precios
np sub 2 será menor de modo que
podríamos decir por causa de la alta
tasa de desempleo que podría producir
una presión salarial los salarios bajan
lo que movería la curva de oferta
agregada a corto plazo hacia la derecha
hay un par de maneras de pensar en esto
podríamos tener más producción a un
nivel de precios dado también podríamos
pensar en un nivel de producción dado
podríamos tener un nivel de precios
menor parte 2 curva de phillips a largo
plazo es esta línea vertical que tenemos
aquí y lo que hay que apreciar en la
curva de phillips a largo plazo o la
curva de oferta agregada a largo plazo
que no cambia a menos que algo cambie
estructuralmente en la economía a menos
que la economía cambie de manera
fundamental tal vez un cambio en los
niveles educativos o un cambio en la
población o un cambio en la tecnología
de modo que aquí diremos que permanece
igual permanece igual
muy bien tenemos más secciones por aquí
vayamos a la parte se identifica una
acción de política fiscal que podría
usarse para reducir la tasa de desempleo
en el corto plazo aquí tenemos que ser
muy cuidadosos nos están diciendo una
acción de política fiscal no política
monetaria si decimos cambiaríamos la
tasa de fondos federales o
incrementaríamos la oferta monetaria o
disminuiríamos la oferta monetaria esas
serían acciones de política monetaria
nos interesa una acción de política
fiscal y esto estaría en relación con la
disminución de impuestos o el aumento de
impuestos o el aumento o disminución del
gasto del gobierno bueno si queremos
reducir la tasa de desempleo una manera
de hacerlo sería mover la demanda
agregada a la derecha y una manera de
hacerlo sería poniendo más dinero en los
bolsillos de la gente y una manera de
hacer eso es reduciendo los impuestos
una reducción de impuestos
dibuja una gráfica correctamente
etiquetada de demanda agregada y oferta
agregada a corto plazo y muestra el
impacto en el nivel de precios de
equilibrio y en el pib real de
equilibrio de la acción de política
fiscal identificada en la parte sé muy
bien déjenme dibujar esto aquí arriba
tenemos nuestro eje de nivel de precios
np y dibujamos algo muy similar acá pib
real y ahora vamos a dibujar nuestra
oferta agregada a corto plazo que ya
vimos antes que tiene una pendiente
ascendente conforme se incrementa el
nivel de precios o la economía está en
condiciones de producir más esta es
nuestra oferta agregada de corto plazo
oa cp
vamos a dibujar la demanda agregada de a
su 1 tenemos la producción de equilibrio
que llamaremos ya su 1 y el nivel de
precios de equilibrio que llamaremos
npc1 ahora si tenemos una reducción de
impuestos eso movería la demanda
agregada hacia la derecha a cualquier
nivel de precios dado la gente va a
querer más van a demandar más porque
ahora tienen más dinero en sus bolsillos
así que esto mover a la curva hacia la
derecha demanda agregada ve a sub 2
ahora tenemos un equilibrio de pib real
diferente este va a ser de sub 2 y
tenemos un nivel de precios
np sub 2 entonces vemos que nuestro
nivel de precios aumenta y nuestra
producción agregada nuestro pib real
aumenta también con base en el cambio
del pib real identificado en la parte de
la oferta de la moneda del país x en el
mercado de divisas aumentará
irá o permanecerá igual explicar pienso
que si tenemos un incremento en el pib
real estamos en una situación en la que
tenemos más actividad económica el
ingreso nacional ha aumentado y si el
ingreso nacional ha aumentado la gente
va a hacer más de todo incluyendo
comprar importaciones y para comprar
importaciones tendrán que incrementar la
oferta de su moneda en el mercado de
divisas porque quieren convertir su
moneda en monedas extranjeras para
comprar esas importaciones de modo que
aumentará aumentará porque el ingreso
nacional aumentó la gente comprará más
importaciones de modo que la oferta de
la moneda del país x para el mercado de
divisas aumentará muy bien parte efe con
base en su respuesta a la parte y
suponiendo un sistema de tipo de cambio
flexible la moneda del país x se
apreciará depreciará o se mantendrá
igual en el mercado de divisas
bueno si mantenemos todo lo demás igual
pero aumentamos la oferta de algo bueno
entonces el precio del mismo disminuirá
si la demanda se mantiene constante pero
aumenta la oferta y eso es de lo que
hablamos en la parte bueno entonces el
precio va a bajar y si estamos hablando
del precio de una moneda y decimos que
está bajando diríamos que esa moneda se
está depreciando por lo que se
depreciara se depreciara y terminamos
hasta el próximo vídeo